Celsius is a billion dollar company that
told its customers to unbank yourself
with crypto but then last year they
declared bankruptcy and sold a new shirt
unbankrupt yourself now at the time I
reported on Extreme incompetence but
stopped short of using the f word fraud
because we just didn't have all the
evidence but today that changes because
of thousands of pages of new court
documents Celsius insiders talking and
my personal interviews with victims make
no mistake this was a gigantic fraud
people's lives have been ruined and the
founder might get away with it so to
help shine a light on this issue here is
my full investigation into the crypto
lender Celsius
so when we're talking about taking back
power it's really not even from the
government it's really from corporations
that dominate our lives and that system
right does now work for 95 percent of
the people on the planet why because the
banks control the money in the world we
talk about all the money in the world
well Celsius does is really helps people
navigate in a safe way into this
environment so when you use a Celsius
wallet you know okay I'm gonna earn
yield and I'm gonna stay safe in the
safe environment because Celsius already
did the homework and figured out what's
safe normally we trust people that we
think are acting in our best interest
but what if these people are not acting
in our best interest what if their
interests exactly the opposite of ours
should we continue giving them our money
or should we take the money and put it
somewhere else
stand Celsius and how they got 30
billion in assets you first have to
understand what they were selling it
wasn't just a place to borrow or lend
money it was more than that it was a
battle against the evil Banks and their
CEO Alex machinski was here to level the
playing field
thanks a lot your friends
but Alex is your friend yes I I have a
lot of my own money in the company uh
several 100 million dollars as well I'm
talking about as a user of the service
not as a equity shareholder and so
basically everybody uh came in and said
hey can I take the same ride on the same
bus with you you're earning 8.8 percent
can I earn it then the answer is yes you
get exactly the same you have a hundred
dollars or a thousand dollars a million
dollars you earn the same yield as
everybody else and this pitch was really
attractive not to mention Celsius
offered eight percent on your money at a
time when your bank probably offered
less than one percent machinski said
this is part of how he was battling the
banks
we basically thought okay how many
people in the world want to earn more
money on their money yield and we said 8
billion people are going to say of
course I want to earn more money on my
money so the customer was there the
second part was we can take on the banks
and win why because 8 billion people are
going to join you and that's what's
really the key to make that decision
then we went and presented it to 200
Venture companies and they all say nope
you're not going to win against the
banks so we went to the community we
actually went to the community said we
gonna build this for you do you want it
and we raised 50 million dollars from
the community and then we went to raised
400 million dollars from investors after
we showed them hey a million and a half
people showed up
30 billion in in assets they've given us
30 billion we've proven that people will
send somebody money to manage or digital
assets to manage and that was really a
breakthrough no one has done that in 700
years of banking there hasn't been
anyone who actually taken on the banks
in the real way this clearly worked
Celsius customers told me that the
reason they switched was just to get a
higher yield on their money
honestly I was looking for a place to
stake and earn interest and earn yield
on my crypto I was actually first in
crypto.com and then I saw Celsius on
YouTube it had higher yields and
everything so I kind of moved my stuff
from crypto.com to Celsius people were
writing about Alex machinsky and all the
messaging on the website you know he's
an entrepreneur that had created all
these companies and he didn't need the
money you know this was billed as a high
yield savings account that was outside
the traditional Financial systems now
look of course in hindsight maybe these
high interest rates should have been
obvious red flags but at the time
because of other crypto projects things
didn't seem so crazy there was also
others that were much much bigger and
much higher you know look at Luna and
stuff like that so in comparison it
didn't seem as crazy at the time but it
wasn't just the competitors who
convinced people it was machinski
himself who gave a really compelling
argument that Banks were lending out
your money and keeping most of the
profit for themselves and he was going
to do something different in the week
paying fees upon fees upon fees they
charge us 24. 24 per year to charge to
basically borrow money on our credit
card they charge us 24 but they pay us
0.1 so where is all that profit going to
right it's going to the toll collectors
so the opportunity is really to for all
of us to again take the go off the off
the stall highway road and go into a new
world where we don't try we don't pay
any tolls we don't pay any fees we act
in our best interest and this is a
division that most people bought into
Alex was going to lend out your money
and pass most of the profits back to you
80 percent in fact and that was the
argument that was repeatedly said I
remember them talking about how 80
percent of their profits were returned
to users as a reward and so that's what
I thought I was doing I thought I was
loaning money to someone that had posted
enough collateral to pay back in the
event of a default we then landed to the
institution the traditional the ones
paying the interest so we've collected
over 700 million dollars of interest
from the institution and distribute most
of that 80 percent of that went to the
retail users 80 of whatever we collected
Celsius next to you are benefiting
because we are lending that collateral
you gave us redistributing 80 percent of
that income with all the other Celsius
it's a win-win-win now of course if
that's not enough to convince you
Celsius also said that in addition to
making high yield they were extremely
conservative they told customers that
there was collateral backing up all
their loans in case of a disaster and
the key thing to understand here is that
this secured loan with collateral is
much less risky than unsecured loans
where there is no collateral and
ultimately Celsius said because of this
A Bank Run wouldn't affect them and
every day we have a process the daily
reconciliation process where our team
like 20 or 25 people
get on a call and grind to all the
tokens and all the coins and make sure
that we have more coins and what we owe
the community right that's our process
and no Bank in the world can do that for
you because they never have enough
assets to return for you if there is a
run on the bank and these promises of
safety and collateralization were key to
people actually putting their money in
with Celsius when I deposited my money
in Celsius I thought their primary
business model was overpowerized lender
I thought they would deposit more assets
than they borrowed money on the platform
and that pay interest to pay return and
so that way I said hey I'm not going to
lose my money because all these things
all the loans over collateralized and
unable to earn the yield and look all of
this sounds great and so far we've been
establishing why people were so excited
about Celsius in the first place so if
that was the case then what's the
problem well the problem was Celsius
went bankrupt and not everything was as
it seemed let's go back to the studio
crypto lender went from managing
billions in assets to filing for
bankruptcy in just a matter of months
CNBC NBC obtained dozens of internal
documents that in part
's organizations prices drop and the
industry faces a liquidity crunch the
collapse of Celsius came as a huge
surprise to anyone listening to Alex
machinski all the way up to shutting
down he had claimed that Celsius had
billions of dollars in liquidity just
ready for withdrawals we have billions
of dollars in liquidity so anyone who
wants to withdraw that's that's a
service you can withdraw at any time so
what happened if that was true why did
it fall apart well the picture wasn't
clear at the time we heard allegations
from people like Dirty Bubble media that
Alex machinski was selling his own
tokens we also found out that Alex
withdrew money off of Celsius before it
shut down but at this point we didn't
fully understand why Celsius had
collapsed was it just incompetence or
greed these were open questions until a
few weeks ago because that's when the
court appointed examiner released her
600 page report detailing exactly what
happened with Celsius in this massive
report report The Examiner details not
only systemic lying a ponzi-like scheme
but also tells us what I think
constitutes fraud here's a breakdown of
the report starting with the biggest lie
of all the interest you'd get on
depositing your crypto you see for years
Celsius had been telling people they
paid what they did because it was 80
percent of their profits they were
earning from all these loans and we're
very proud as well to pay out over 80
percent of our revenues directly back to
the community and so this is something
that we are going to continue to do and
we look very carefully at all of our
numbers on both sides to make sure that
we are doing that and that's also what
is helping us decide the rates of every
single week that we're paying out on
coins but this was a lie according to
the report Celsius did not distribute up
to 80 percent of its revenues to its
customers because it had little to no
profits to even distribute Celsius also
made no efforts to set its reward rates
based on its yield and look I know what
you're thinking if they didn't set the
rewards based on what they actually were
making as a company what did they set
them based on well I'm getting more
customers and according to the report
Celsius consistently set its reward
rates based on what they perceived was
necessary to beat the competition and
for most of celsius's existence the
rewards it paid exceeded by substantial
amounts the revenues Celsius could earn
so for those of you following along the
whole idea that we're paying 80 percent
of what we make was a total fabrication
Celsius just wanted more customers which
as you might imagine works when you're
bringing on more assets with new users
than you're paying an interest but
eventually when you have billions of
dollars in assets you have to pay
rewards based on that and the Celsius
team realized they had a problem but
even as some within Celsius management
attempted to lower reward rates
machinski quote overrode their
recommendation and refused to do so one
example of this was when Jason Perman a
Celsius executive recalled machinski
saying that Celsius could not cut its
reward rates because of his belief that
our customers will leave us and that
quote our investors didn't invest in us
to shrink they invested in us to double
so with this new understanding that they
weren't going to be able to lower reward
rates they realized they were stuck with
the other strategy trying to raise what
they were able to make with their assets
by employing riskier investment
strategies to try to get closer to
profitability
and guess what
they lied about this too even as the
company started to make riskier
investments like offering unsecured
loans machinsky told people the opposite
he said everything was business as usual
Celsius is very very strict at who we
lend to right so we all in land to the
first tier institutions first tier
exchanges we do not to do all kind of
unsecured lending like a lot of people
are talking about or saying Celsius does
unsecured we do not do unsecured lending
but of course this wasn't true Celsius
internally had been talking about the
number of unsecured loans they were
giving out increasing shown here in
Orange and internally on slack
Executives were Furious quote I just
told him that the number is increasing
and the overall ratio of collateral with
institutions is going down another
executive responded Yes so why does he
publish so dangerous statements everyone
out there if you have an unsecured loan
tell everyone that I'm a liar but in the
end no one did call him a liar even as
he literally asked for it here I'm
calling on anyone anyone who received an
unsecured loan go on Twitter make a fun
out of Alex machinski say hey I took a
loan here's my loan number you know I
took a loan from Celsius and I did not
have to provide at least 200 collateral
and through the next year mashinski
continued to boast about how safe
Celsius was even as the team began to
engage in riskier behavior in the same
year Celsius would recognize 800 million
dollars in losses from some of these
Investments koshinsky told the financial
times in June 2021 this from a risk
standpoint we are probably one of the
least risky businesses that Regulators
worldwide have ever seen around the time
he was saying this Celsius was over a
half a billion dollars under water on
their liabilities as shown by the black
line which represents a net Surplus by
the end of the year 2021 Celsius would
owe a billion dollars that they did not
have things were looking bad
wait a minute wait a minute I thought
you said this was a fraud it is a fraud
maybe to you coffee
there's another way of looking at this
what do you mean well imagine I'm
defending Celsius as a lawyer you're a
mixologist and a lawyer hey I could pass
the bar if I wanted to I already work at
one but anyways what I would say if you
were coming in my client is look all
this lying and losing money
standard fake it till you make it stuff
they could have become profitable
eventually
now if they fail yes
but trying a business and failing
that's the American dream coffee do you
actually believe that though it doesn't
matter what I believe if a single person
on that jury was an entrepreneur Alex
would walk well
either way your hypothetical doesn't
even matter mashitzki isn't even being
criminally charged wait really
well I rest my case then yeah nice try
but it's not that simple they're still
suing him for some of the money he's
just not being criminally charged and
let me guess you don't think that's
enough no I don't think it's enough I
mean it's a slap on the wrist it's a
financial speeding ticket for a guy who
ruined so many people's lives but that's
my point coffee if you think it's so
wrong you gotta give me more than this
but how you said it yourself they're
just gonna claim incompetence they faked
it till they didn't make it ah but
that's because the evidence so far is
lies and incompetence you need to show a
definitive step across that line that's
the only way people are going to believe
you
well that and what well this might be
ironic coming for me but it wouldn't
hurt to humanize the story a bit don't
get stuck in the technical jargon nobody
can follow that make me feel something
as much as it pains me to say this I
think you might be right let me see what
I can do
what does that money mean to me means a
lot actually I've been working since I
was 14. I was investing this my first
couple of jobs out of college ultimately
stopped us from buying a house because I
mean it was half of our down payment was
locked and you know I couldn't get it so
it was a big impact actually honestly
that loss was a culmination of many
years of work to be quite Frank I saw it
as my way to escape what that money
means to me it's a lot more freedom with
uh what we're able to do as a family to
describe what the money I lost meant to
me is really hard because it's tied into
a lot of what it feels like to be a
grown-up or an adult I I feel like I I
have this stunted developments you know
I'm almost 40 at this point and I'm very
aware as a man that wants to be physical
if we have a kid last year like we
wanted all right maybe by the time he's
20 I could show him some stuff but the
longer we wait more I watch my my dreams
and my future and my hope to be like a
proper functioning adult slipped through
my fingers it's it's hard to describe
what that's tied into but it just feels
like I can't proceed with life if that
makes sense that does make sense and
hearing these stories made me realize
just showing lies isn't enough if I'm
gonna demonstrate fraud I need to get to
the heart of Celsius and that's when I
found out about the flywheel the
flywheel was Central to celsius's plan
to become profitable and here's how it
worked Celsius was not just a crypto
platform they also had a crypto token
called cell and they controlled the vast
majority of it up to 95 so if the price
of cell went up theoretically the
balance sheet of Celsius would also go
up and they could sustain these insane
reward rates however in order to do so
they needed people to actually want cell
token so the flywheel was machinsky's
plan to do that to create a positive
feedback loop and the way they did this
was set up cell token like a Rewards
where you could earn bonus interest if
you held a certain amount of sell which
obviously incentivizes people who wanted
to get the most out of their accounts to
buy and hold these sell tokens on their
website they describe this process as a
self-sustaining ecosystem where users
would buy sell earn more yield get more
crypto collect interest earn more yield
lend more coins collect more interest
and buy more sell tokens now of course
you might notice a problem here what if
people actually go to sell their sell
tokens wouldn't that crash the price
well machinski had an answer for this
too he told the community that Celsius
would buy sell tokens in order to pay
their rewards theoretically creating
demand out of thin air here's him
explaining this basically more visitors
usually translates to more app downloads
and that translates to more deposits
more deposit allows us to do more loans
more loans generate more income and more
income means more income that Celsius
generates from these coins that people
people gave us translated to us having
to buy more Bitcoin ethereum sell token
and so on so okay that's the flywheel
why does it matter well the flywheel and
this cell token became the place where
all sorts of shenanigans happened with
Celsius because while the community was
aware that they were buying back sell to
pay rewards what they didn't know was
that Celsius was using customer funds to
do so to buy their own coin what they
imagined they were doing was that they
were using all this profit they were
theoretically generating from making
these loans to buy their own token but
that wasn't the case this was because as
we said earlier Celsius wasn't really
profitable at all so the only money they
had to buy sell token was their own
customers money but it gets even worse
because starting in 2020 Celsius decided
to substantially expand its purchases of
cell for the purpose of increasing sales
price instead of buying sell when it
needed to pay rewards Celsius began
timing its purchases so that they would
prop up sales price by creating activity
in the market now of course the question
is here why would Celsius go beyond its
mandate to purchase more sell than
necessary and artificially boost the
price well perhaps it has something to
do with the top holder of Celsius being
machinski and his Executives and this
was the only way they could sell some of
these tokens without crashing the price
according to the investigation quote
between 2018 and June 2022 Mr machinski
sold at least 25 million cell tokens
realizing at least 68.7 million dollars
on these sales Daniel Leon also a
founder of Celsius sold at least 2.6
million in cell tokens for at least 9.74
million dollars as well that's a cash
out of over 70 million dollars while
Celsius was buying these sales to
prevent the price from going down quote
Celsius often increased the size of its
resting orders to buy all of the cell
that Mr machinsky and his other
companies were selling the former Chief
Financial Officer would write we are
talking about becoming a regulated
entity and we are doing something
possibly illegal and definitely not
compliant some employees of course were
even more direct quote if anyone found
out about our position and how much our
Founders took in USD could be a very bad
look we are using users usdc to pay for
employees worthless sell and even worse
in 2022 their coin deployment specialist
described their practices of buying up
sell and using customer coins as very
ponzi-like and a few weeks later when
this person was asked where money was
coming from to buy sell this person
would say users like always this ladies
and gentlemen is the core story not
merely lying it's a story of using
customer funds to buy out your
Executives and manipulate your own
cryptocurrency so you can sell for a
higher price in fact celsius's own
purchases of their own tokens were such
a large component of the market that
overlaying the price of Celsius with the
amount that Celsius was buying results
in a near perfect match of the price
change and ultimately what this meant
for the end user is that the money they
thought were being used for safe loans
or for generating yield were actually
squandered on this flywheel mechanism
and the result was that Celsius just
didn't have the money to pay customers
back and what's so wild about this is
that Celsius didn't even need to buy
their own cell token in the first place
they already controlled 95 of all the
cell tokens in existence so they could
have just paid rewards from that instead
of buying sell on the open market when
asked why they did it this way one
executive responded that the answer lies
and who holds the most sell in other
words buying sell on the open market was
what propped up the price which
benefited no one more than Alex
who Executives would refer to as the
biggest seller by far and depressing the
market selling up to 165 thousand
dollars a day as a result of all these
actions by the time Celsius would pause
withdrawals they had a shortfall of over
7 billion dollars owed to customers
which after a crypto crash was more like
four to five billion dollars either way
hundreds of thousands of lives were
ruined and this in my view is where
Celsius crossed the bright red line
rather than just being an incompetent
lender they had created a scheme with
cell token where new users funds had to
be used to prop up sell token value
which benefited their Executives it also
created a need to use new customer funds
to pay out old customers because of
their impossibly High rates of rewards
to fuel growth according to the examiner
this all meant that Celsius Network on a
standalone basis has been insolvent
since Inception this meant that new
users always had to keep on coming in to
keep machinski's flywheel going and when
they stopped coming it was doomed to
collapse this is the textbook definition
of a Ponzi scheme where new users
deposits are required to pay old users
withdrawals and according to the
examiner this actually happened
explicitly multiple times one example is
from June 2022 when Celsius relied on
33.4 million dollars of usdc of new
customer deposits to fund withdrawals of
old customers which Celsius couldn't
afford and this unfortunately is the
real story of Celsius a Ponzi scheme
designed as a way to take on the banks
and fight for the little guy but hey
don't take it from me I'm just a third
party take it from the victims
themselves I asked them what they
thought so this was an absolute fraud
from the beginning I mean it turns out
that a lot of these businesses that they
claim to be propping up Celsius were
completely fraudulent from what I've
seen from The Examiner more and more it
looks like it was just a a textbook case
of a Ponzi scheme I don't care if it was
apology scheme from the very beginning
or the very end it still was a Ponzi
scheme it doesn't matter if he meant to
start a Ponzi scheme right but the
second Cube got into those circumstances
it it becomes fraud they were basically
losing money from the very start of the
company and they're literally lying in
front of everyone's faces saying yeah oh
it's totally fine yeah you could totally
keep our money in here yeah I would
totally invest more if I could as
they're currently at that same time
withdrawing funds as they're looting on
camera locked everyone's faces she made
a lot of egregious claims on his Twitter
on his website on his podcasts he would
do claiming uh if Celsius ever went
bankrupts all the customers would get
all of their funds back you know there's
tweets of him saying that and as a CEO
of a company you would take that word at
face value you would believe him when he
says your coins are going to come back
to you and now that everything's coming
to light and showing that essentially
what he was running is a Ponzi I do
believe he should face showtime and the
people that were also involved with it
that were enabling that behavior there
needs to be an example set where we're
going to see more of these grifters in
these in this space like sambeck and
freed and others who just take advantage
of people who believe in the technology
who believe in Innovation and you're not
supposed to steal people's money just
plain and simple you know it's uh it's
called theft it's a Ponzi scheme just
being strict of all of your wealth like
that emotional psychological torture you
ruined people's lives Alex you ruined
their lives man I've seen so many people
who are retired I've seen people who are
disabled I saw people who are basically
in like different types of countries
that their average salary might be a
hundred dollars a month and they lost a
thousand dollars and they don't even
know how to feed their families I've
seen people who are literally on the
verge of being homeless if not homeless
already and you see this CEO who is
gloating about this and taking money out
I think without a doubt if like the
justice system prevails Alex should be
in jail
well that's our story I reached out to
Alex machinski about these allegations
and he declined to comment except to say
I should talk to a Celsius employee
named
to clear up the fud now I talked to this
employee but they declined to go on the
record themselves and when asked if
anyone within Celsius wanted to speak
with me I was told nobody is willing to
go on the record with you so that's
where we're going to leave that and as
for Celsius the company they're trying
to reopen their doors they have a new
plan to basically distribute whatever's
left back to the holders and lawyers and
I'm not going to go too much into the
details of this plan but if you're a
creditor you can visit this page to
learn more it's not a perfect plan by
any means but I'm not sure I have any
better ideas of what to do with such a
bad situation so that's it for me for
now I hope the way it was worth it guys
for this video uh we're trying to level
up the production behind the scenes so
if you enjoy uh all the in-depth
investigations please consider
supporting us on patreon these videos
are a lot of work to produce but either
way I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
oh
foreign